[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 débat en ce mois de
novembre c'est la troisième édition de
l'opération mois sans tabac elle connaît
un démarrage avec 185 mille personnes
inscrits dépassant le chiffre de 2010
est de 15% selon le rapport de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé si
aucune mesure n'est prise d'urgence pour
endiguer l'épidémie de tabagisme le
nombre annuel de décès pourrait
atteindre 8 millions d'ici 2030 paquets
neutres interdiction de fumer dans lle
dans les lieux publics augmentent acte
augmentation du prix du paquet de tabac
est ce une lutte efficace c'est le débat
du jour avec nous en plateau ce soir
pour en parler à dame claire farina
psychiatre addictologue ocs ap hm centre
de soins d'accompagnement et de
prévention en addictologie attrape et
monsieur jean-françois vigouroux
président de la délégation des yvelines
des buralistes
bonsoir parce qu'on dit merci d'être
venu sur le plateau pour savoir si les
mesures mises en place pour lutter
contre le tabagisme fonctionne ou non
je voudrais vous faire part de quelques
chiffres officiels la france compte près
de 16 millions de fumeurs dans la
tranche de 18 34 ans une personne sur
deux fume et selon le baromètre santé
publique france il y à une diminution
des fumeurs hommes passant de 57% dans
les années 1960 à 32% en 2018
en revanche il y à une augmentation des
fumeuses les femmes fument plus 26% en
2018 alors qu'elles n'étaient que 10 %
en 1960
avez vous fait ce constat je m'adresse à
vous monsieur vigouroux en tant que
buraliste avec vos clients et à vous
madame farina avec les personnes qui ont
pu venir dans votre centre
alors oui tout à fait c'est un chiffre
qui est connu ça a fait suite
un côté assez cool avec beaucoup de
publicité autour de la cigarette pour
que les femmes s'émancipent et c'est
donc ça a été associé à cette image donc
les femmes se sont mises à fumée autour
des années 60 et on voit surtout
malheureusement beaucoup de pathologies
liées au tabac elles rejoignent les
hommes
en termes de mortalité c'est quasiment
multiplié par 10 avec des pathologies
surtout pulmonaire des cancers les
problématiques cardiovasculaires qu'on
connaît qui sont liées au tabac et on
voit heureusement dans nos consultations
en addictologie de plus en plus de
femmes qui viennent nous consulter pour
arrêter le tabac et vous dans votre
honneur on va à une clientèle ses mixes
et les femmes kim autant que de sa
session vous avez pu constater une
évolution évolution non non on voit pas
comme je peux pas vous dire oui je on
vend plus de femmes que d'hommes ou par
rapport à il ya dix ans mais c'est vrai
que les femmes fument autant que les
hommes pour moi ces cessions à présent
je vous propose de regarder ce qu'en
pensent les yvelinois des mesures pour
lutter contre le tabagisme
on aurait beaucoup plus taxé le tabac
c'est source de penser à autre chose
très néfaste pour chacun et je vois pas
pourquoi on ne taxe pas beaucoup plus
touba on voit aucune publicité à la télé
dans les médias quand qu'il faut
sensibiliser les jeunes leur montrer un
petit peu en plus des atrocités sur les
paquets de cigarettes je pense que ça
les arrête pas acheter des paquets de
cigarettes pas du tout je trouve que
c'est très bien de faire des campagnes
contre le tabac je pense qu'il faut
justement continuer dans cette démarche
de réduire la consommation du tabac en
france compte tenu de l'impact sur le
quand même la santé des gens
et puis aussi pour les caisses de l'état
pour l'assurance maladie
c'est une question de volonté mois brûlé
son argent d'abord c'est une erreur
fondamentale
ça va partir en révolution au bout d'un
an quand le paquet sera à 20 euros ou
quoi que ce soit il ya les mois sans
tabac c'est bien pour être solidaires
avec ceux qui veulent arrêter mais ceux
qui veulent pas arrêter de fumer et qui
sont prêts à y mettre de l'argent dedans
ils mettront on multiplie les mesures
mais c'est surtout quand on le touche au
porte monique ça marche le mieux pas sur
moi sinon bien sûr que à chaque fois
qu'on augmente on diminue ont diminué
les vans je pense pas que le paquet
neutre soit bénéfique parce que les
photos choc
maintenant on les voit même plus je ne
sais pas si si vous vous regardez les
paquets enfin moi je suis devant toute
la journée mais le fumeur il est pareil
je ne sais pas si c'est ça c'est plutôt
de la prévention de l'éducation taxer
plus ce tabac je ne sais pas si on peut
le taxer plus enfin 80 plus de 80% de
taxation je veux bien mais le problème
c'est que plus on augmente au prix et
puis on va faire de la contrebande et la
contrefaçon et qui est des fois plus
dangereuse que que tu mets entre
guillemets du du tabac du jeu reste donc
augmenter le prix du paquet de tabac
emmène les fumeurs à acheter ailleurs
augmenté le tabac si on veut passer le
paquet à 10 euros je dirais que pour la
santé publique
on n'est pas contre par contre il
faudrait une harmonisation de des pays
européens n'est pas normal que l'on
trouve en france à 10 euros si on trouve
au portugal à 14 50 donc oui on va
baisser nos chiffres nos chiffres filles
les chiffres officiels vont baisser au
niveau des ventes de tabac mais au
niveau de la contrebande
elle ne fait que de monter on est
quasiment à 25% du 2
de cigarette fumée de tabac de
contrebande le paquet neutre c'est
quelque chose qui marche pour lutter
contre cette addiction
alors l'objectif du paquet neutre c'est
surtout que le paquet soit repoussant et
du moins moins cool que ce qu'il a pu
être par le par le passé le fait
auparavant les marques de cigarettes
avec des emballages très attractif avec
des couleurs un truc assez classe des
choses qui étaient plus centré vers un
public féminin des choses plus pour les
jeunes actuellement comme ils sont tous
assez repoussant sa cible aussi beaucoup
le public jeune
le fait que les paquets soir poussant le
jeune ne va pas forcément aller vers
cette consommation est un des objectifs
de cette campagne qui a débuté donc il
ya quelques quelques années ça a surtout
été aussi de viser les jeunes on voit
que le tabagisme chez les jeunes recule
et l'objectif du gouvernement est aussi
d'arriver vers des générations sans
tabac avec des jeunes qui seront pas
confrontés au tabac et donc de les
protéger de cette confrontation parce
qu'on sait que plus on est confronté au
tabac jeune et plus on a des risques de
développer des addictions
on sait qu en australie le fait que le
paquet neutre est été instauré ce a
diminué beaucoup l'image du tabac et
diminuer le
la vision que les gens avaient du tabac
voir le tabagisme alors l'australie
c'est une île c'est pas exportable à la
france bien évidemment on voit quand
même que ça un impact le prix du paquet
de tabac il avait diminué en 2004 une
première fois quand il était passé à 7
euros
on avait vu une diminution aussi pas
seulement des ventes mais aussi du
nombre de fumeurs
et là on a eu les chiffres assez
récemment sur le baromètre santé de 2017
et on voit que l'augmentation des prix
du tabac permet de faire chuter
l'incidence du tabagisme y compris sur
ce qu'on n'arrivait pas trop a touché
jusque là qu'étaient les classes les
plus défavorisées et le tabagisme chez
les jeunes
et justement ces personnes sont ils
assez en forme et alors probablement pas
c'est aussi pour ça qu'on est intéressé
de venir à des émissions comme la vôtre
pour pouvoir informer les gens et aussi
les informer de toutes les mesures qui
sont mises en place pour pouvoir
permettre l'arrêt du tabac nous reçoit
très régulièrement des fumeurs qui des
fois on en discute et un petit peur
plateau ne prend même pas qu'ils peuvent
arrêter de fumer et en pratique ils
viennent nous voir et au bout de
quelques mois la consommation diminue
puis s'oriente vers un arrêt depuis peu
ça faisait aussi partie du plan du
gouvernement
les patchs sont remboursés et de plus en
plus de substituts nicotiniques donc les
gommes à mâcher les pastilles etc sont
remboursés et vont permettre aux gens
d'avoir accès à tous ces éléments et ces
temps dangereux pourquoi ne pas arrêter
le tabac où se diriger vers les vapes
aurais tu nous en tout cas pendant le
mois de son tabac les buralistes propose
mois d'avant pour développer cette façon
entre guillemets d' de transformer la
cigarette traditionnelle car c'est un
des moyens pour arrêter qui restent
d'après là et reste un des moyens les
plus fous on arrive à arrêter de fumer
donc pour nous si vous voulez on n'est
pas contre une politique de santé
publique
on va dans ce sens là et c'est pour ça
qu'on le propose et que vu que 40 42 %
nos clients sont des non fumeurs mais
69% des clients vapoteurs sont issus du
marché traditionnel de la cigarette
donc on connaît nos clients et on veut
vendre nos produits de reportages et
pour sortir de la tête de la dépendance
du tabac aller vers des cigarettes
électroniques saeed ce drame alors ça
c'est quelque chose qu'on ne sait pas
encore la cigarette électronique n'est
pas un médicament ça a été développé par
d'autres sociétés
il ya eu des questions étaient faits en
étudiant la fumée des cigarettes et la
fumer la cigarette électronique
on sait qu'il ya qu'elle est beaucoup
plus sûr et qu'il ya vraiment beaucoup
moins de substances dangereuses dans la
fumée de la cigarette électronique
après nous on sait aussi que ce qui a
été développé par les firmes
pharmaceutiques que sont les substituts
nicotiniques sont des éléments sur
valider pour arrêter le tabac
donc on a plutôt tendance à orienter les
gens qui viennent nous voir vers les
substituts nicotiniques que sont les
patchs les gommes et cetera on encourage
quand même vivement la consommation de
cigarettes électroniques y compris pour
ceux qui sont pas sûrs de vouloir
arrêter la cigarette pour pouvoir
diminuer les risques et les exposer mon
à la fumée du tabac et le tabac est ce
que c'est pas une question de clientèle
il ya eu un mythe sur fumer ça peut
aider les femmes à maigrir ou il ya
cette image de virilité est ce que
derrière tout ça c'est pas une
une question demeure de clientèle
peut-être qu'avant oui avec le paquet
ça favorise et ça faisait bien de fumée
maintenant je pense moi je pense que
c'est plutôt une addiction que c'est une
envie plus donc pour faire bien oui tout
à fait tout à fait le tabac d une image
très positive il ya quelques années on
voit encore le côté le côté récompenses
sympathique
plus ça va plus on voit des gens qui
commencent à nous dire que ça ne sert
plus à rien que limite ça fait certains
sont même un peu ringard quand ils sont
les seuls à sortir pour filmer leurs
clopes d'or il ya de moins en moins de
gens qui ont cette image positive du
tabac à l'est plus en plus et c'est
aussi l'objectif du plan du gouvernement
c'est de décaler et de montrer aux gens
que le tabac c'est un véritable poison
et que fumer il vaut mieux passer des
moments conviviaux entre amis en
éloignant la cigarette et en dissociant
le côté sympathique et conviviale la
consommation de tabac est justement vous
en tant que buralistes le tabac c'est un
poison de tabasser oui c'est pas va pas
dire c'est un peu long mais c'est vrai
que c'est compliqué c'est parce que
c'est un produit qui peut entraîner des
maladies donc bon comme je vous ai dit
on n'est pas contre la santé publique on
fait tout pour aller dans le sens
l'interdiction de vente aux mineurs ou
de paquets neutres on fait tout ce qu'on
nous demande de faire maintenant il faut
on demande un accompagnement c'est ce
qu'on a vu d'ailleurs avec notre
ministre de tutelle gérard darmanin avec
un avec des aides qui vont arriver par
les buralistes pour se moderniser pour
sortir de cette image ringard de
buralistes qui vend que du tabac et on
veut vendre autre chose dont dont des
comptes en banque
des cigarettes électroniques de plein de
choses que qu'on peut avoir besoin dans
la vie tu as les gens et pour clôturer
ce débat à l'occasion du mois son tabac
une petite conclusion oui donc le mois
sans tabac c'est un événement qui permet
à chaque fumeur qui devrait permettre à
chaque fleur de perdre faire le point
sur sa consommation où il en est s'il a
une volonté d'arrêt à plus ou moins long
terme
il ya énormément de d'initiative
énormément de centres
donc moi je travaille au centre
d'addictologie de trappes qui est dans
les locaux de l'institut de promotion de
la santé
on organise deux journées portes
ouvertes de mercredi après-midi le 7 et
le 28 novembre après midi où les gens
pourront venir librement avoir des avis
des professionnels de santé tester
certains substituts nicotiniques et c
est le centre de consultation de
versailles de rambouillet font également
des actions merci à vous d'être venu
c'est la fin de ce sept huit débats on
se retrouve mercredi prochain d'ici là
vous pouvez retrouver cette émission en
replay sur tv 78 points com ou sur notre
application
merci très bonne soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]